ja putins oligarchen freunden werden die
yachten weggenommen putins gas freund
gerhard schröder jetzt die mitarbeiter
der staat und also die steuerzahler
sollen schröders privilegien als an kalt
kanzler nicht länger finanzieren müssen
büropersonal wir reden hier von rund
400.000 tausend euro kosten im jahr das
soll nach bild informationen an diesem
donnerstag im haushaltsausschuss
beschlossen werden ein beispielloses
vorgehen in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik gegen einen ehemaligen
kanzler
gerhard schröder
altkanzler gas lobbyist und putin freund
seit 2005 genießt er dass altkanzler
legte rente viele mitarbeiter doch damit
ist jetzt schluss nach
bild-informationen geht's gerhard
schröder jetzt an den seidenen poussin
finanzierten kragen mitten in berlin 1 a
lage hinter mir ist das brandenburger
tor und hier unter den linden 50 das
büro von gerhard schröder sein
altkanzler büro in einer 1a lage fünf
mitarbeiter hatte da oben schon seit
2005 die verlieren jetzt aber leider
ihren wunderbar bezahlten job denn die
ampel koalition greift durch alle seine
angestellten raus keine mitarbeiter mehr
für gazprom geht
unfassbar für diese behaglichen
räumlichkeiten und das personal sollte
die staatskasse im vergangenen jahr
satte 400 7000 euro finanziert von den
deutschen steuerzahler bereits seit
april plant die bundesregierung wie sie
schröder die mitarbeiter streichen kann
jetzt macht auch die union offiziell
druck mit diesem antrag für den
haushaltsausschuss am kommenden
donnerstag in diesen fordern die
christdemokraten die streichung der amts
ausstattung von gas lobbyist gerhard
schröder wegen seiner russland nähe
neben den mitarbeiter stellen sollen
auch die haushaltsmittel für
versorgungsleistungen und reisekosten
wegfallen einzig den personenschutz soll
schröder behalten dürfen so der unions
antrag notwendig dafür ist die
zustimmung der ampelkoalition und es
scheint als steht alles auf grün es ist
das bisher härteste durchgreifen der
regierung in der causa schröder bereits
im vergangenen monat forderte
finanzminister und fdp chef christian
lindner die personalstreichungen es ist
für mich nicht mehr vorstellbar dass für
ihn ein büro vom steuerzahler gestellt
wird ehemalige inhaber von spitzenämtern
die offenbar an der seite
verbrecherischer regierungen stehen
können nicht auf die unterstützung
dieses staates zählen
zuvor sorgte der altkanzler deutschland
und weltweit für empörung mit seiner
russland nähe kurz vor beginn von putins
blutigem angriffskrieg in der ukraine
wird der alt-kanzler dem westen
säbelrasseln vor trotz putins bomben die
täglich unschuldige ukraine ermorden
behält gazprom gerd seiner
aufsichtsratsposten auch bei rosneft
neben seiner fetten altkanzler rente 1
millionen nebenverdienst direkt aus der
russischen staatskasse nachdem der druck
aus der deutschen politik wächst fliegt
der altkanzler selbst zu seinem freund
dem kreml tyrann putin inszeniert sich
als friedensengel und vergessen der
bizarre post von schröder gattin kim
ende april dann das sonderbare interview
mit der new york times weil viel
weißwein plaudert putin lobbyist
schröder über seine freundschaft zum
kreml türen das bild das die menschen
von ihm hätten sei nur die halbe
wahrheit während putin weiter bomben auf
die ukraine wirft
wir wollen dass schröder büro
konfrontieren
das war nichts die wollten nicht mit uns
sprechen obwohl sie im haus sind zum
mitarbeiter rauswurf will sich heute
niemand äußern kein statement aus dem
büro von gas lobbyist und putin freund
schröder still ruht der see daran sollte
sich die büro gemeinde schröder will
jetzt gewöhnen
und wir reden darüber mit bild politik
schäfer jan schäfer der uns zugeschaltet
was sind die hintergründe wieso kamen
jetzt der durchbruch
tatsächlich zu streichen haben den
beitrag von victor wachs ja gerade ganz
ausführlich auch gesehen es gibt seit
monaten muss man schon sagen was 7 und
über gerhard schröder seine extreme nähe
zu blatter mir putin in dieser unmut hat
sich nach beginn des krieges des
angriffskrieges auf die ukraine durch
wladimir putins truppen noch mal
verstärkt und gerhard schröder stehen
derzeit bis zu sieben mitarbeiter
stellen zu die der steuerzahler bezahlt
und bis zu sechs büroräume und nach
unseren informationen gab es also jetzt
heute das entscheidende gespräch der
ampel verantwortlichen es wird am
donnerstag entschieden werden dass
gerhard schröder auf büro und
mitarbeiter stellen künftig kein
anspruch mehr hat man fragt sich ja bei
der gelegenheit jan was machen
eigentlich diese altkanzler
beispielsweise und die ganzen
mitarbeiter auch angela merkel die ja
jetzt altkanzler ist alt kanzlerin ist
oder denken wir an die ganzen
bundespräsidenten joachim gauck ein
horst köhler einen christian wulff die
nebenbei bemerkt ja auch noch ihren
lebenslang ehrensold von 200.000 euro an
was machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag
noch für den staat dass sie so viele
mitarbeiter brauchen ist eine sehr
berechtigte frage thomas und es war
bisher in deutschland tradition dass man
den bundeskanzler und auch den
bundespräsidenten die dann nicht mehr
amt sind zugestanden hat dass sie noch
einen gewissen büro staab erhalten denn
es gibt natürlich noch viele anfragen
für vorträge beispielsweise für reden
gehalten der in sorgues und teile auch
repräsentative ausgabe auftritte wie
christian wulff tritt ja auch im ausland
immer mal wieder in vertretung
beispielsweise des amtierenden
präsidentin auf also von daher gibt es
aufgaben die ausgeführt werden und für
diese aufgaben hat sich ja die
bundesregierung haben sich die
koalitionäre überlegt gibt es immer eine
gewisse apanage für das ehemalige
regierungsoberhaupt oder den ehemaligen
bundespräsidenten so und das ist
unabhängig von dem sold den der
ehemalige bundeskanzler oder
bundespräsident ohnehin erhält aber und
das ist natürlich jetzt zu diskutieren
wenn ein bundeskanzler dann schon 17
jahre 17 jahre wie bei gerhard schröder
außer dienst ist ist wirklich die frage
ob er noch so einen großen star braucht
und im fall von gerhard schröder ist
natürlich dann sowieso ganz klar der
verdient millionen in russland er
braucht das was ihm der steuerzahler
hier in deutschland zur verfügung stellt
und bezahlt überhaupt nicht jan schäfer
vielen dank für die einordnungen